però tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono trovato con il signor gatto
su un altro totali a kuwait però e non è
batte il grande e delivery service e
quel gioco dove devi beh non saprei
spiegarlo perché è un po difficile ha
spiegato guardatelo che merita buona
visione
sì organi mi spieghi non so niente più
strane customizzato perché siamo troppo
uguali non è vero dobbiamo portare
questa cosa fragile va bene va bene
allora prendiamo allora abbiamo di
riuscire a fare una cosa proprio serio
serie b io guido ma grappolo reso che
salga ma non così tanto i pen ok
perfetto vado è io lo tengo perché se lo
mollo che è fragile stia attento che
fragile e io lo tengo fermo lo tengo
vorrei aggrapparmi a questo conto perché
ho una paura immensa chi è captarono
nostri avrebbe ridotto mollandolo
mollato come la volata ai raggi con quel
che costa non ci pagano poi queste è
fare un pezzo del computer nuovo sicuro
la nuova scheda nvidia per giocare a
questo gioco
malick e pelati sì ma non è vero c'è che
per gli arancioni stesso colore
bastava vietato rosa tamada aiuto alla
fine mese come se fosse solo albero il
signor gatto c'è la somma e quindi lei
allora lo so è va bene facciamo guidare
anche sul curioso di vedere tenga il
pacco perché è difficile non si dice
allora no non in questo senso è caduto
da banco ha vissuto il resto divenga
pavia signora il pacco signora aiuto e
avevano rubare veloci attenzione lo
portano a mano arrivo io dalla una mano
e niente non ce l'ho fatta aspetti che
resiste e non so devo farla pure esista
ma il pacco lo 88 ben chiaro che la vela
sul casinò ritiro i capelli ecco mi
arrivò a salemi che venga venga vengano
dai no che c'è il cosa aspetta così
esposta si sposta più e va beh niente va
bene niente niente
sono a posto le prime di loro ha ripreso
sono libero per ok distratto salga salga
veloce che non via scansanese scappa
scappa sta andando stanando aspetto
venga qui o al san gallo veloce però
prima che arrivi perché questa riva
sagra fatto già arrivato si è aggrappato
va bene fa niente perché tenga il parco
ma lei sembra un'idea intelligente è per
investire lui ma lo stiamo toccando le
ruote non riesco a tirare e vabbè mi ha
scoraggiato dosso mantenga tenga ma le
scoregge ti fanno tornare tenga tutto
dove dobbiamo andare a destra ci siamo
quasi a ians manca pochissimo
vi faccio priva tanto e distrutto il
pacco ormai aia ma allora non ha un
senso diciamo che poi anche facendolo
serio ma questo qua si può staccare la
stampa ok l'altro è andato quali ha mete
ok come te che cosa vuole ma mi sono
aggrappato a un aiuto
la consegna il consiglio lomazzo questo
qui ti ammazzo mal consigliato posto
nostro
vana la donna aveva sono tutti facciamo
tutti i patti lo stesso team e quindi va
bene qualche bel team ma equa che girava
bene prendiamo un altro
ecco qua allora lei li vide nuzzo del
fattori over si le primarie ed è così
certo io mi aggrappo all'elicottero
mentre va mi sembra correre aspetti che
però ok vada vada no non scappa qualche
vaso
non ho la maniglia alla maniglia equa la
base si aggrappa al barile si aggrappa
barile piazza il barile si è non riesco
però è difficile petti spetti si tolga
archer cacchio perfetto petit che forse
riesco
guardi detto ma sono proprio no strano
arrivati di farci a veloce veloce veloce
signor gasoli chiostraccio subito io
faccio io e dovevano ma solo la somma
era la base non è però perché siamo
uguali non è allora questi progetti che
verranno che sono più interessate quello
che facciamo ha clonato desco no ma devo
nel lusso andiamo
e dove li spinga meeting e pighi che
pighi pd ok non potevano vederlo c'è un
raggio in calendario aver aver veloci
alla ce lo vedo però non vedo l'ufo
waiting for start è il successo non c'è
un ufo 4 nero in modo che ciò che leggo
non è scoppiata roba qui aiuto succede
siria arrivarci ma non ero perso
rifaccia sto rifacendo si muova perchè
qua e voi che avete le stime deve
schivare deve schivare barsa bar non è
un delivery ci colpiscono e rischi va
chi vale per ultimo aperto ma siamo in
piena venuto via di qui e challenger
incredibile a o mio dio no sfilato per
la fine per molto nella cuffia 9 uccide
ce l'ho fatta avessimo ciò che abbiamo
capito prova a dare fastidio ma finirà
prima o poi penso rimanga anche se con
di un minuto con me posso tornare su
non lo so però è stato sta facendo molto
più veloce la fase difficile
madonna adesso avevo complicato adesso è
velocissimo venga venga e che venga non
posso
siamo a livello di crash bandicoot ma
svelo sente il bordello detto tutti simo
socio capo di ritornare su un attimo io
sto cercando veramente di è provi che in
arrivo è ma non so usato l'estintore
arrivo vorrà perché qua è difficile non
so quanto resi
allora io sono molto più in alto
rispetto a dove partono in laser ho
perso subito perché era un casino
bellissima questa veramente a se
facciamo cerchio e babà cioè ci lascia
morire dov'eravamo morti va bene sono
l'elicottero se vieni qua forse la lila
response
stino il 9 si arrivò che mi ha fatto un
bellissimo ovunque questa feature merita
tutto quando il prezzo del biglietto
pagava le apprezzo di tutto il biglietto
io mi sono incastrato e non so come
uscirne
intanto metto il coso su è l'aspetto che
si tenga il prossimo che ho scoperto la
telecamera in società veramente strano
eh sì perché il tasto della telecamera
usi anche il braccio destro o ci sono o
dio
ok allora qui ci sono due elicotteri uno
li marco mi atterro bene e uno qui c'è
un jet
devo subito nell'incontro delle palle e
solo volevano parole insieme belice
attacchi di eduardo lara tantissimo
signor gattino questo incredibile
aspetti aspetti
a me non ha la faccia però lei alle
spalle e tutti che il fianco a caso
proprio il motorino sono attaccato
attaccato al raffronto vecchietto
aspetti assicuri ma dai vada vada parte
ci sono io vado perché su 6 ago ricavi
poi non lo so che botta e risposta
dobbiamo ritrovare anche al giorno fuori
un picco aprirla ma non puoi suonare in
nessun modo la prego bellissimo
aspettive
ce l'ho fatta a fare a partire
mamma mia e bellissimo aveva vennero
però ad attirarla in corso sarà buona
idea 20 che non vedo due o mio dio molto
giù ma non può buttarsi nell'acqua
facciamo prima e ma l'acqua me respon ha
poi in spiaggia non mi porta di un altro
niente mi devo aggrapparmi sta
aggrappando in modo tale da non darle
peso
venga modo tale da non garbi per vedrai
no perché io prima e roero inclinato ma
non ci stiamo siamo due coloni no ci
provi va bene di base si attacchi a
qualcun altro giorno no no no no no no
in una slancio ok solare tra l'altro no
in realtà vogliono dare il diritto solo
che non gira sto girando anche io col
corpo lo facciamo la facciamo
bravissimo anti lega adesso allora
mentre nuova bellissimo vada dove vuole
ma è incredibile
se sa guidare questo mi mette la gioia
creed vada a destra lei f e un fenomeno
levità e dell'emozione
guarda che roba pazzesco bellissimo
questo penso sia la punta del giorno non
si schiantino no io vorrei girare a
destra e non ce la sto facendo quindi in
giro anche io non mi sbilancio niente
bellissimo signori dopo ore di volo
brevetti della casa e io il signor gatto
siamo stati bravissimi
lasciatemi piaciuto che ce lo meritiamo
e si vede anche il canale il signor
gatto e noi come sempre ragazzi ci
rivediamo al prossimo vinto bella
ragazza
[Musica]